RATHER THAN CALL FOR VIOLENT
HARASSMENT AND MOB RULE."
HOLDER IS PREDICTABLY
BACKTRACKING.
TWEETING "STOP THE OUTRAGE.
I'M OBVIOUSLY NOT ADVOCATING
VIOLENCE.
IN FACT WHEN I WAS AG, VIOLENT
CRIME IN THE U.S. WAS
HISTORICALLY LOW.
I AM SAYING REPUBLICANS
UNDERMINING OUR DEMOCRACY AND
DEMOCRATS NEED TO BE TOUGH,
PROUD, AND STAND UP FOR THE
VALUES WE BELIEVE IN.
THE END."
DANA, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
REALLY WORKS IN POLITICS IS WHEN
YOU MAKE YOUR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS FIGHT AMONGST EACH
OTHER.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
YOU HAVE MICHELLE OBAMA,
HILLARY, ERIC HOLDER ALL
FIGHTING AMONGST EACH OTHER AND
THAT HELPS THE RIGHT.
>> Dana: DO KNOW WHO WOULD NOT
HAVE APOLOGIZE?
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
I DO THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT THE WINGS, ESPECIALLY ON
THE LEFT WING RIGHT NOW, WANTING
A FIGHTER.
WHY WOULD YOU APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT?
YOU COULD SAY HE GOT A LAUGH OUT
OF THE CROWD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS LOTS OF
THINGS TO GET A LAUGH FROM THE
CROWD.
THE LEFT SAYS WE CAN'T BELIEVE
HE SAID THAT.
HE WAS TERRIBLE.
NOW THE RIGHT IS SAYING THAT
ABOUT ERIC HOLDER.
IT'S ALL ABOUT PROPORTIONALITY.
>> Jesse: I AM GOING TO USE
THE FAKE OUTRAGE NEXT TIME.
>> Dana: AVENATTI WOULD NOT
HAVE APOLOGIZE.
>> Jesse: IT'S FUNNY,
DEMOCRATS DEBATING ON WHETHER
THE TAKE -- TAKE THE HIGH ROAD.
>> Greg: ACCUSING AN INNOCENT
MAN OF GANG RAPE IS NOT EXACTLY
THE HIGH ROAD.
WHERE DOES --
BEFORE I GET INTO MY SERIOUS --
I WILL SAY I BELIEVE WHAT HOLDER
IS SAYING BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
THE PRINCIPLE THAT YOU DON'T
TAKE THE WORST MEANING OR WORST
INTENTION OF WHAT SOMEONE IS
SAYING.
I DON'T BELIEVE HE WAS INCITING
VIOLENCE.
HE WAS BASICALLY SAYING FIGHT
HARDER.
HAVING SAID THAT, ACCUSATIONS OF
INCIVILITY DON'T BUG ME.
I THINK INCIVILITY IS PRETTY
GOOD BECAUSE IT REDUCES THE
CHANCE FOR VIOLENCE.
IF YOU ARE UNCIVIL WITH EACH
OTHER, IT MIGHT MEAN YOU MIGHT
NOT PUNCH.
THE THING THAT BOTHERS ME IS THE
INCITEMENT AND ENABLING OF A MOB
SO WHEN YOU HAVE NETFLIX
EMPLOYEES FOR EXAMPLE STOCKING
BRIAN KILMEADE IN ORDER FOR A
SHOW ON NETFLIX AND THEN
INCITING THE PASSENGERS ON THE
SUBWAY TO JOIN IN IN THIS ORGY
OF PERSECUTION.
PERSECUTION IS LIKE A CONTAGION.
WHEN YOU'RE IN A MOB, IT IS
SPREAD THROUGH REPETITION.
IT CAN HAPPEN VERY EASILY.
HE THINK WE NEED TO CONTRAST
WORDS AND DEEDS.
WHAT HOLDER IS SAYING IS USE
WORDS BUT YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE DEEDS.
PEOPLE ARE COMPARING
DONALD TRUMP, HIS WORDS, TO
LEFT-WING DEEDS.
I GET IT.
TRIM CAN BE RUDE IN HIS JOKES
CAN BE MEAN BUT THERE IS NO
RIGHT WING ANTIFA OR OCCUPY
WALL STREET, NO SCALISE SHOOTING
MORE PEOPLE RIGHT WING CHASING
PEOPLE OR RIGHT WING NIGHT FLEX
-- NETFLIX.
>> Jesse: I DIDN'T THINK
HOLDER WAS LITERALLY TALKING
ABOUT KICKING REPUBLICANS.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE SENSE THAT
BUT GREG'S POINT, IN THE CONTEXT
OF ALL THE OTHER DEEDS THAT HAVE
GONE ON IN THE LAST WEEK, MONTH,
YEAR WHERE THERE'S BEEN VIOLENCE
AND THREATS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, IT DOESN'T ADD ANYTHING TO
THE CONVERSATION IN A POSITIVE
WAY.
>> Juan: I THINK IT DOES.
I THINK BOTH DANA AND GREG SAID
TO YOU, JESSE, THAT WOULD
DEMOCRATS WANT OUR PEOPLE WHO
WILL STAND UP AND FIGHT FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC BRAND.
RIGHT NOW REPUBLICANS CONTROL
THE WHITE HOUSE, CONGRESS, AND
THE SUPREME COURT AND OFTENTIMES
THEY FEEL LIKE, REMEMBER THE USA
TODAY PIECE.
THAT THE PRESIDENT GETS AWAY
WITH SAYING THINGS ARE UNTRUE
AND NO ONE STANDS UP AND SAYS
THIS GUY IS MISLEADING YOU,
REPUBLICANS.
WHERE DID YOU GO, REPUBLICAN
PARTY?
I LISTEN TO YOU GUYS AND I THINK
WAIT A SECOND.
WHAT KIND OF ONE-SIDED
PRESENTATION IS THIS?
THIS GUY WAS AT RALLIES AND HE
HAS TO CROWD YELLING "LOCK HER
UP."
NOT ABOUT HILLARY.
ABOUT DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
>> Greg: CLEVER.
>> Juan: AT THE SAME TIME ONE
HOLDER SAYS DEMOCRATS NEED TO
STAY
STAND UP.
THEN YOU SAY THERE'S NO
SHOOTING?
STEVE SCALISE, THAT WAS AN
ACTIVE HORROR.
YOU HAVE TO ADMIT THEY WENT INTO
A PIZZA PARLOR IN WASHINGTON.
>> Dana: YOU HAVE BROUGHT THIS
UP EVERY TIME.
THE PIZZA PARLOR THING.
CAN I SAY?
>> Juan: WHAT ABOUT
CHARLOTTESVILLE?
DID THEY RUN OVER SOMEONE AT
>> Dana: I THINK
CHARLOTTESVILLE --
>> Greg: LET ME FINISH.
WHEN IT COMES TO REPUBLICANS CAN
WE HAVE TO BE HONEST.
IT'S A BUG IN THE SYSTEM.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE LEFT, IT'S
THE SYSTEM.
YOU'VE HAD THE WEATHER
UNDERGROUND, SLA, BLACK
PANTHERS, MANSON FAMILY, ANTIFA.
REPUBLICANS HAVE NOTHING LIKE
THAT.
>> Juan: YOU HAVE WHITE
NATIONALISTS.
>> Greg: THE OPPOSITE OF WHITE
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> Jesse: JEDEDIAH, WHAT DO
YOU THINK?
>> Jedidiah: YOU BOTH GAVE
HOLDER THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT
AND THAT'S GREAT AND I PROBABLY
WOULD TOO.
BUT HE WOULDN'T GIVE YOU -- IF
ONE OF YOU SAID THAT, FORGET IT.
I THINK THIS ALL STARTED WITH
THE REFUSAL TO ACCEPT THAT TRUMP
HAD WON.
STARTED WITH THAT AND PEOPLE ON
THE LEFT SIDE YOU KNOW WHAT,
THIS WAS NOT A PROPER ELECTION.
THEY INCITED EVERYBODY TO SAY
THAT THIS ELECTION WAS NOT
TANGIBLE AND THEY SHOULD RALLY
AGAINST IT AND IT STARTED WITH
MAXINE WATERS.
THESE ARE MANY LEADERS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
PEOPLE TALK TO ME ALL THE TIME.
TEA PARTY RALLIES, THE SIGNS
THEY SAW AT TEA PARTY RALLIES.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT SIGNS
AND HAVE SIGNS OF PEOPLE AT A
RALLY, I'VE NEVER FOUND IT
OFFENSIVE.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT
COMPARED TO LEADERS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, HOLDER,
HILLARY CLINTON WHO COULD HAVE
BEEN PRESIDENT, SAYING
OUTRAGEOUS THINGS.
GOOD ON MICHELLE OBAMA WHO CAME
OUT AND SAID THIS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
I'M SURE HILLARY CLINTON WAS NOT
HAPPY WITH HER BUT I COMMEND IT
IT WENT SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS, IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE WITHIN THE PARTY ITSELF
TO STAND UP TO IT.
ANY DEMOCRAT TO STAND UP TO
THIS, I SALUTE THEM AS WELL.
>> Juan: I WISH THE
REPUBLICANS WOULD STAND UP TO
SOME OF THE OUTRAGEOUS --
>> Jedidiah: MANY REPUBLICANS
STAND UP TO DONALD TRUMP WHEN HE
SAYS SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN WHEN WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
I DON'T WANT TO LITIGATE LOCAL
VIOLENCE BUT GREG WAS PICKING UP
A LOT OF EXAMPLES OF I WAS
YESTERDAY, LEFT-WING ATTACKS ON
REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS, CABINET
MEMBERS, TRUMP FAMILY MEMBERS,
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
THAT HAS BEEN VIOLENCE
PERPETRATED BY THE RIGHT ON THE
LEFT IN THE STREETS, AND THAT'S
AWFUL AND RANDOM.
BUT WHEN YOU ARE GOING AFTER
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP IN A
DEMOCRACY THAT TAKES IT TO A
HIGHER LEVEL AND I THINK THAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE.
>> Juan: GOING AFTER POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP?
>> Jesse: RICIN, THREATS
AGAINST FAMILY MEMBERS, CHASING
THEM AROUND IN THE STREETS.
THAT'S AN ATTACK ON POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP AND NOT SOMETHING --
DRIVING INTO A CAR OR SHOOTING
UP A RANDOM PIZZA PLACE.
I'M NOT EXCUSING IT.
I'M SAYING IT'S DIFFERENT
CATEGORICALLY.
>> Juan: IT'S DIFFERENT IF
SOMEONE STANDS UP AND SAYS I
DISAGREE WITH YOU.
I THINK MITCH MCCONNELL, WHAT
YOU DID, I'M IN THIS AIRPORT AND
I'M NOT GOING TO LET YOU HEAR
IT.
>> Jedidiah: HARASSING